that being said you think it's easier to
work on your own or to have quote
collaborators I think that is always
easier to work on your own that it's
never better I think that you know I am
so skeptical of anybody who says they're
a writer director actor producer editor
they're not good at all those jobs
there's one or two they're good at and I
think that when people say they are
multi - it's with all those things they
usually are not good at any of them be
one or two things and be good at them
that will make your work better and so I
can live in isolation and and
technically could I direct edit produce
shoot technically I could I
I know how to do all of those things but
I know what I'm best at I'm a good
director I'm a good editor and so I will
sometimes do those two things and even
when editing work I've directed if I
think that I'm not being disciplined
enough or if I'm not being judicious or
I'm lost in the woods I always bring in
a second editor because I can't be
Precious about it in my own work because
that looks poorly on me as a director
right so you have to be cognizant of
those things so could you work on your
own and do your own thing sure you can't
but your works going to suffer I think
most people that do that their work does
suffer there are very few examples of
people that are successful with that I
don't think most people can pull that
off but in the middle let's say I mean
be starting out maybe they can't afford
yeah oh yeah when you're starting in
half - right that's now that's different
right like if you're starting out sure
like why I first started out I yes I was
producer director editor all of those
things but if you want to make that
transition to the middle the middle best
place you can't you can't do that
anymore you you have to set that aside
and you have to start leaning in on and
working with people who are
professionals in
those areas I don't think you would go
to using the accounting example a CPA
who is also a chef who is also an uber
driver you would probably think that one
of those things they may not be very
good at it's the same thing in the film
and maybe the need to hire out it means
that you are entering the middle right
what also I think shows that you're
entering a different mindset right
because there are two kinds of
filmmakers I think there's the
professional filmmaker which I'm lucky
to be now and then there's the ones that
do it for themselves who just kind of
make it and they have the regular job
and and that's what they do that's
totally fine neither one of those are
bad or wrong but if you're going to be a
foam professional you've got to work
with other people because they are
trained specifically in specialty areas
that you are not and if I'm trying to do
all of those things I'm in veritably
going to drop one of those balls or not
do one of those things well because I am
not trained I am NOT a lawyer who took
the bar and passed it I am NOT going to
write my own contract because I took an
entertainment law class in college that
does not make me a lawyer that means I
might understand basic verb ologies and
structures but I'm not going to have
myself write my own contract with the
company to direct a film because I know
that that doesn't make me good at it
that means I know something about it I
will hire the lawyer that's been trained
in entertainment law that passed the bar
that is practicing in multiple states to
do my negotiations for me it's the same
thing with hiring a crew would you hire
a lawyer do you I do your only go I
don't think so
I don't want to do that I'm not trained
in it I'll screw me over in the end
same thing will happen if you try to do
everything yourself
you